I'M SORRY I BEG YOUR PARDON I
WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM YEAH
THE SAME. NO WAS MY FAULT I
SAID GO I KNOW YOU DO I SAID GO
YOU WENT BECAUSE I. LIKE WE ALL
KNOW WHO WE ARE. JUST BETWEEN
FRIENDS BUT WE HAVE TO. OKAY
ROLL CALL PLEASE. MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HERE REMAIN HERE FLORA
CHILD CHILD HERE EGGMAN YEAH
THE IMAM SIMONE HERE MATHIS
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY. MELENDEZ
MULLIN IS HERE. STONE STONE
HERE. THANK YOU. EVERYONE
PLEASURES. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EYES AND- THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD THIS IS A GREAT
BILL AND WE'RE REALLY HAPPY TO
HEAR IT HOWEVER THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REAL ESTATE DISCLOSURE
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY THE
CLEANUP OF SIGNED INTO LAW.
THIS WILL YOU COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH MY COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY TO CLEAN UP THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE RULES
EXCLUSION NEXT YEAR. WITH THAT
YEAH BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL. A ROLL CALL PLEASE A
BASIN IN THE SENSE QUESTIONS.
I'M SORRY DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR. YOU
CAN SPEAK NO NO NO BUT LIKE.
I'M SORRY. I USED TO BE. YEAH I
AM SO SORRY. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. MEMBERS LUCASARTS ABOUT
THE NATURE RECENTLY FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS CONCERN OR
OPPOSITION. DON'T BE SHY. OKAY
HEARING NONE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CLOSE OKAY SIGNAL
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. WITH US
HERE AT LOEWS OKAY WE ROLL CALL
OFFICE AT THIRTY EIGHT I
REMEMBER WHAT THE MOTION IS
THAT THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA. CHILD CHAU
AYE AND WHEN. GARCIA I FIRST CO
I LIVE ALONE HI THE MOMENT I
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN DESIGN
RIGHT TO TRY. TO SHE AYE STONE
SO I. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCLUDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THREE ALTHOUGH
ONE SOURCE ABSOLUTELY WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR SEVEN
MINUTES OR SO. WE WENT
. THEY
DIDN'T PLAY NINE TO. FIVE
THAT'S PRESLEY FOR THE SENATE
OKAY
. YEAH